surely they are one of the most famous
families in India a Bollywood dynasty
but now the button family are hitting
headlines for testing positive for
coronavirus first it was announced that
77 year old Amitabh Bachchan and his
actor son Abhishek has been admitted to
an isolation ward of the Nanavati
Hospital in Mumbai suffering from mild
symptoms the star announcing the news on
social media I have tested kovat
positive shifted to hospital hospital
informing authorities family and staff
undergone tests results awaited all that
have been in close proximity to me in
the last 10 days are requested to please
get themselves tested then came the news
that his daughter-in-law an actor
Aishwarya Rai and her eight-year-old
daughter have also tested positive their
family home in Mumbai wants a pilgrimage
site to millions of fans now declared a
containment zone no one allowed to enter
or exit the premises and the cars and
the grounds of the house sprayed down
with disinfectants Amitabh Bachchan is a
household name having dominated Indian
cinema for more than five decades he's
been involved in no 200 films and
successfully crossed over into Hollywood
more recently the government has used
his high profile to spread awareness of
how to fight coronavirus India is a
third worst affected country in the
world after the United States and Brazil
each day the number of positive cases
are rising and so is the death toll
which has exceeded twenty two thousand
six hundred so far the state of
Maharashtra and particular its capital
Mumbai has become the country's Cove in
19 epicenter so far more than 200,000
cases have been confirmed and more than
5,000 people have died there
most part of the city is so densely
populated that social distancing is
non-existent today's news is a warning
that no one is immune to the impact of
this deadly virus never Lazarus Sky News
India